- Britney Spears wins big in court.
She wins the right to
hire her own attorney
who can advocate for her own rights.
In the most recent
conservatorship hearing,
the judge accepted the
resignation of her former counsel
and accepted the appointment
of her new lawyer, Matthew Rosengart,
who comes from a very
prestigious, very large law firm,
Greenberg Traurig.
Now Rosengart is a former
federal prosecutor.
He seems to have lots of experience
and I'm sure will represent
Britney Spears very, very well,
but it's odd that he doesn't appear
to have much conservatorship experience.
You would think that in a
high-profile conservatorship,
like the one that Britney Spears is in,
that she would hire
someone who specializes
in conservatorships to
make sure that she's able
to get out of this conservatorship.
So we will see what happens next.
And we will see all of them in court.